propose de commencer avec cette loi
bioéthique qui est temps mais ce n'est
pas son seul objet la procréation
médicalement assistée aux couples de
lesbiennes et aux femmes seules
cette loi après un long parcours
législatif a été définitivement adopté
hier comme l'a proclamé richard ferrand
le président de l'assemblée nationale
voici le résultat du scrutin votants 483
exprimer
441 majorité 221 pour 326 contre 115
l'assemblée nationale a adopté le projet
de loi
voilà le cette loi a été l'objet de
débats très vifs d'opposition de fond à
l'intérieur de la semaine nationale mais
aussi opposition au sénat
c'est l'un des reproches qui est fait
à ce texte par ses opposants c'est qu'
il n'y a pas eu de consensus sur ce
sujet écoute et loïc hervé il est
sénateur union centriste de haute savoie
on a un acharnement sur le vote de cet
de cette loi avec l'extension de la pma
aux couples aux couples de femmes et aux
femmes célibataires avec un certain de
disposer de dispositif notamment en
matière de bioéthique que moi je
comptais que sais je trouve dangereux ce
type de loi il mérite une forme de
consensus national consensus national
qui n'existe pas et qui ne peut pas
exister de fait par rapport à la
situation politique que nous vivons je
pense que on aurait dû temporiser sur
cette loi pour ne pas fracturé une fois
de plus le peuple français ce sujet là
en même temps gabriel cluzel si on
attend que des consensus sur tous les
grands sujets ben on légiférera jamais
donc c'était peut-être inévitable nom
qui essaie d accord alors non je ne suis
je ne suis pas d'accord enfin c'était
inévitable qui est des désaccords mais
ce n'est pas inévitable de la voter si
c'est ça la question d'ailleurs on
remarquera au passage que le désaccord
entre le sénat et l'assemblée montré que
les dernières élections n'étaient pas si
inutile parce que je rappelle les gens
n'ont pas voté pour les régionales
pensant que c'était inutile mais c'est
que c'est quand même là où l'on décide
des grands électeurs qui ensuite
choisissent le sénat et on voit que le
sénat à l'occasion peu un jouer un rôle
des positions même s'il n'a pas le
dernier mot
mais en l'occurrence il a fait entendre
sa voix moi ce qui me choque déjà c'est
que ça a été voté dans un contexte de
démocratie altérée c'est à dire que très
objectivement et tout le monde le sait
avec cette cette crise sanitaire elle
est là la démocratie n'a pas fonctionné
normalement alors on dit oui non ça a
été discuté à l'assemblée
ça n'a pas été discuté par exemple n'y a
pas eu de couverture médiatique que cela
méritait alors que c'est proprement
intrinsèquement philosophique est ce que
les gens savent ce qui est exactement
dans cette loi moi je ne suis pas du
tout sûr du reste qu'un sondage de
l'ifop qui est sorti sur le sujet alors
c'est vrai que là là là le ceux qui ont
fait passer cette fois ont gagné le
la guerre des mots alors pas parce que
pma pour tout ça fait gentil ça inclusif
on veut être gentil avec tout le monde à
éviter voilà c'est merveilleux mais en
réalité ce que contient cette loi les
français le savent assez peu est ce
qu'ils savent par exemple non ils ne
savent pas ils le savent pas du tout est
ce qu'ils savent qu'on va rembourser et
je ne connais pas de précédent faire
rembourser par la sécurité sociale
un traitement pour des personnes qui ne
souffrent pas de pathologie ça c'est
quand même un pied dans la porte qui
absolument extraordinaire puisque alors
on a beau appeler ça une stérilité
sociale ce n'est pas une série litée
biologique donc on va rembourser à des
femmes une procréation médicalement
assistée qui ne souffre pas de stérilité
biologique les est ce que dans ce
contexte où resserre les défenses de la
sécurité ce n'en est qu'un parmi
d'autres incarnent exemple à d'autres
véhicules
est ce que les gens savent jeu ça encore
je n'en suis pas convaincu et le sondage
a montré le contraire que cette loi a
agréé l'idée que vont être faits des
embryons chimères hommes animaux c'est
tellement incroyable que même le
quotidien avait fait un reportage là
dessus en se moquant des opposants à
cette loi en disant mais non il raconte
que des bêtises c'est complètement
dingue
effectivement complètement dingue voilà
donc c'est si vous voulez il ya un
certain nombre de points est ce que les
gens savent que deux avec cette loi les
femmes qui autrefois avaient accès à la
pma pour des raisons de stérilité vont
se retrouver face à une pénurie de
gamètes et donc ça sera plus à pma pour
tout comme son nom l'indiqué est
il ya tout un bataillon de raisons qui
montrent que les français n'ont pas du
tout été correctement informés et que le
gouvernement a voulu donner un clin
d'oeil à vue sociétal
faute de réussir à attirer la gauche
sociale je vais donner la parole bien
sûr à six matches jamais jeu là je vous
donne d'abord le point de vue de nos
internautes la loi bioéthique est elle
une avancée sociétale et bien il ya une
majorité des gens qui ne regardent qui
répondent non 57,7 % et puis voici
quelques avis celui de claudius 15 qui
considère que cette loi pma ne fait
qu'entériner et légaliser une pratique
courante
la pma di volpe a dû 30 cartes qui est
d'accord avec gabriel cluzel ne devrait
pas être remboursés pour les femmes qui
n'ont pas de problèmes de santé il faut
penser aux enfants
c'est aussi l'avis de l'olympe d'olympe
dg pardon et vous juste mais déjà quel
est votre point de vue là dessus les
français vous pensez et elles savent que
cette loi permettait au couple de
lesbiennes de d'avoir recours à la pma
c'est pour ça d'ailleurs que les
opposants à la loi la plaie la pma 100
perd donc ce point n'a été identifié
mais il y en avait aussi d'autres
à votre avis les les costauds rien et
est conscient de ce qui se passait à
l'assemblée non seulement ils nos
concitoyens savait parfaitement ce que
contient cette loi mais majoritairement
ils y sont favorables
ils y sont favorables tout simplement
parce que le droit en l'occurrence ne
fait que reconnaître une évolution de
société ce n'est pas la première fois
d'ailleurs que la société précède le
droit ces arrivées de très nombreuses
reprises dans dans notre histoire
institutionnels aujourd'hui un certain
nombre de femmes femmes célibataires
femmes homosexuelles sont contraintes
pour pour bénéficier de la procréation
médicalement assistée sont contraintes
d'aller à l'étranger en belgique au
danemark en espagne ça coûte souvent
très cher entre 10000 et 20000 euros
selon le nombre de tentatives
il y à 2500 femmes de notre pays qui en
ont bien voilà il fallait on est
exactement dans la même situation que
quand on a reconnu le droit à l'inter
sur volontaire de grossesse c'est à dire
qu'à un moment donné il faut arrêter il
faut ouvrir les yeux sur une évolution
de la société
là le modèle familial a changé il n'est
plus le modèle qu'on a longtemps connu
un père une mère
voilà ce modèle a changé aujourd'hui
c'est une réalité il y à des enfants
très heureux dans d'autres types de
modèles familiaux et bien le parlement
et c'est tant mieux
vient de reconnaître cette réalité donc
moi je crois que c'est une une avancée
positive c et vous verrez et vous verrez
vous verrez que dans 10 15 ou 20 ans on
ne se posera même pas la question de
savoir si on a bien fait de voter cette
loi ou pas de la même façon
qu'aujourd'hui une personne ne remet en
cause le fait que le parlement a pu
voter en 1974 la légalisation de l'ibg
et bien je pense qu'il en sera
exactement de même pour cette loi tout
simplement parce que il faut que la
société reconnaisse aujourd'hui une
évolution et c'est bien que dès que les
femmes qui sont confrontés à ces
questions c'est bien qu'elle soit
sécurisée
il ya un cadre aujourd'hui enfin il y à
un cadre juridique et sociale qui permet
de sécuriser enfin sur la question de la
sécurité sociale il faut pas agiter des
épouvantails s'éteint c'est un acte
médical
et comme tout acte médical c'est normal
qu'ils soient remboursés il ya quand
même des limites qui sont fixés il ya
une limite d'âge il ya le nom un nombre
de tentatives enfin il ya quand même un
certain ya un cadre qui a été fixé un
cadre juridique qui est très précis et
moi je crois que ça je pense que
d'ailleurs vous avez remarqué que les
mobilisations contre cette loi
elles ont eu un écho mais quasiment nul
très faible très faible pourquoi on
n'est plus du tout à l'époque de la
manif pour tous mais pourquoi parce que
les français se rendent compte que ça ne
sert à rien d'opposer ça ne retire de
droit personnes cette loi c'est s'il n'y
a pas eu précisément l'écho qu'il aurait
cette loi aurait dû rencontrer c'est
précisément parce que la démocratie
encore une fois n'a pas pu s'exprimer
comme elle aurait dû le faire c'est à
dire tout le déploiement de
manifestations d'information n'a pas été
fait et par ailleurs l' usage
d'acronymes lénifiant comme procréation
médicalement assistée pma pour tout
jette un voile pudique sur la réalité
parce que quand vous faites des sondages
vous demandez aux gens mais c'est
important d'avoir un père ah oui c'est
important
et vous trouvez que c'est grave de
priver quelqu'un de son père oui c'est
grave parce que vous dites on va
développer d'autres modèles familiaux
c'est pas vrai c'est pas vrai c'est un
mensonge tout ce que j'ai à la à la base
d'une famille a toujours le père la mère
et l'enfant on a beau se rouler par
terre ça reste la wii sauf qu'on occulte
le paie on le met de côté du reste d'une
d'une façon qui n'est pas encore très
clair parce que c'est vrai qu'on se dit
que avoir accès à ses origines ça va
être compliqué de convaincre si on a les
enfants ont accès à leurs origines on
veut bien convenir que c'est compliqué
de paragon assez exactement il ya un air
biologique
voilà exactement c'est à dire que sans
père biologique il n'y a pas d'enfant
logique déterminer s'il ya une réalité
puis quand même enfin c'est incroyable
de turin donc j'ai passé une audition
qui a un siècle encore maintenant
laissez moi parler chose et laisser
parler donc le il est évident que le
père biologique a une importance et tous
les enfants adoptés vous le diront donc
y aura une recherche de père biologique
tôt ou tard qui intéressera l'enfant et
on convient quand même aujourd'hui que
de ce fait ça peut-être avec compliqué
d'obtenir des dons de gamètes
parce que ses pairs hésite sans doute à
avoir une flopée d'enfants qu'il qu'il
ne maîtrise pas donc ça c'est ça c'est
une réalité
dire à un enfant qu'il a deux mers c'est
tout simple que demers et lui mentir
nous sommes d'accord il ya un verre
biologique ça nous sommes d'accord donc
sur ce plan là il faut être
il faut être très clair par ailleurs
vous dites c'est une avancée sur
laquelle on ne reviendra pas on se dira
dans dix ans que
c'était aulas on trouve ça tout naturel
est rigoureusement l1 vit inverse du
vôtre je pense précisément on a fait
passer l'idée du reste on est passés
d'étape en étape c'est la stratégie des
petits pas chinois c'est ce que dit
aujourd'hui un journaliste de libération
il dit il ya des étapes intermédiaires
comme ça maintenant il faut passer à la
gpa donc on est passé de 2 par exemple
du mariage pour tous à la pma puis on
nous prépare dès aujourd'hui 12 heures
après le vote de la loi à passer à la
gpr voiliers et bien je crois moi que ce
ne sont pas que le thon ce n'est pas
inéluctable compte on peut revenir en
arrière et je crois qu'un jour on se
réveillera et comme dans le conte
d'andersen vous savez vous connaissez le
roi y nul vous savez les habits neufs de
l'empereur
on nous dira mais on était complètement
fou écouter moyennant et je termine vous
pensé au cou voilà où il a excusé moi je
termine je conclus et je veux vous
montrer une preuve qu'il arrive qu'on
revienne en arrière c'est que vous si
vous avez lu
un certain nombre de livres qui sont
sortis récemment vous avez pu vous
rendre compte que dans les années 60 70
80 même le climat n'était pas le même il
y avait des choses qui étaient
considérés comme des progrès et qui
aujourd'hui nous choque voulez que je
vous donne un exemple
là par exemple dans le film de mamiya
grande et c'est là je vous laisse par
contre c'est la pédophilie voilà la
pédophilie au conseil a été considérée
et ben aujourd'hui on considère que
billie jean c'est un écoutez moi ce que
je sais que ce que je sais ce que je
fais avec une conviction absolue c'est
qu'il y a des enfants parfaitement
heureux épanoui dans des dans des
familles qui sont constitués de couples
d'hommes ou de couples de femmes ou de
mères seules ou deux personnes
ce n'est pas ça qui détermine qu'un
enfant est heureux ou pas et dans ces
cas-là ce que ce n'est pas ça qui fait
que l'on grandit qu'on sait pas nous y
que l'on est
collomb on a de l'amour de la part de
ses parents ce n'est pas ça et ce n'est
pas la biologie qui détermine le bonheur
d'un enfant et compte tenu de sa vous
êtes favorable à la gestation pour
autrui alors puisque nom n'existe nom
vous dit non parce que c'est un must
magouilles avion vous disiez pour la pma
puisque ça existe c'est l'état de la
société il faut légaliser la gpa aussi
exigeant l'évoqué hommes qui ont recours
à des couples d'hommes qui ont recours à
des mères porteuses à la ga pour un
problème majeur des tic
c'est le problème que la gpa c'est de
recourir à une tierce personne
aujourd'hui je parle tels que ceux
pratiqués aujourd'hui pour porter pour
une grossesse c'est de recourir un tiers
est souvent de le payer et souvent de le
payer aux états unis c'est une pratique
courante
on ne voit là donc on sait entre 50000
et 100 mille dollars
des mères porteuses en californie et
dans d'autres états ça là il ya un vrai
problème d'éthique c'est à dire est ce
que est ce que le corps est une
marchandise
je ne le crois pas et je pense qu'il
n'est pas il n'est pas bon d'aller vers
une commercialisation de la grossesse et
de l'acte d'enfanter donc pour moi la
limite lll et elle est posée à ce niveau
là mais on a pas en ce qui concerne la
pma on n'est pas du tout dans cette
logique là et je suis extrêmement choqué
et extrêmement choquée de voir comment
on peut procéder par amalgame est
finalement
lycée comme ça avec des exemples pour
aboutir à l'idée que y aurait peut-être
un problème pma pédophilie mais enfin
c'est dingue de dire des trucs pareils
c'est complètement dingue c'est
extrêmement choquant et franchement
aujourd'hui c'est l'intérêt de l'enfant
c'est l'intérêt de l'enfant mort sinon
mais non d'un séjour effet ces gens
d'éviter ce genre à te dis que tous les
progrès pardon que que tous les progrès
parce qu'ils sont étiquetés progrès et
parce qu'il se répande dans la société
d'une façon qui paraît consensuel parce
que certains peut-être qu'ils ont des
voix dominante le disent c'est ce n'est
pas pour ça que ce progrès là est une
bonne chose et je vous cite l exemple de
la pédophilie
si vous lisez le le bouquin familia
grande et vous voyez que pendant les
années 70 c'était considéré comme un
progrès aujourd'hui on est revenu en
arrière quand j'en ai donc expliqué
c'est que un sérieux manque de mémoire
sur un certain nombre de points qui
pouvaient être considérées comme des
progrès une loi en urgence et être
rétrogradé à la chose on ne pense pas
non bientôt les gens voulaient non mais
attends je vais mélanger je vous réponds
ne parle pas d'une malade et nayer
s'étant notamment des bagues d'un climat
etc
on parle d'une loi il n'y a jamais eu de
l'ouest il c'est un film et de la
société
voilà oui mais n'y a jamais eu aucune
loi qui a légalisé la pédophilie vous
reconnais attendez on dans libération
pour la pédophilie comme aujourd'hui il
y en a pour d'autres d'autres même si
c'est dans leurs différents droits et
les besoins de progrès pour a battu son
corps s'est révélée serait un progrès
pour les femmes nana est une très bonne
chose
cramer fin des discriminations sam effah
un archaïsme et la france aurait dû
l'adopter sans doute depuis d'ailleurs
c'était c'était dans le programme de
françois hollande est malheureusement
comme sur d'autres sujets il y avait
renoncé voilà un dernier mot sur wii non
mais est-ce que
est-ce que je peux prendre rendez vous
avec vous puisque vous dites aujourd'hui
cpa non pas dans dix ans dans deux ans
peut-être ou trois ans je ne sais pas
vous dites que la gpa c'est mal c'est
pas bien alors je dois vous dire que
gérald darmanin et bruno le maire disait
de la même chose de la paix mais pma il
n'y a pas si longtemps et aujourd'hui
ils ont visiblement avaler leur chapeau
et ils ne disent rien en tout cas ça
leur avance à n'a suscité aucune
réaction
donc j'aimerais que pour une fois nous
soyons clairs là-dessus hausse dans deux
ans vous viendrez me dire voilà bon très
bien et va écouter j'en suis ravi nous
donc prenons rendez vous ce sera parfait
et dernier point vous dites il ya des
enfants heureux c'est un risque
un raisonnement spécieux que j'entends
beaucoup et des enfants heureux dos
c'est vrai bien sûr je remercie qui a
des enfants une re dans et bien sûr
malheureusement des fous pcc famille
bien sûr mais deux de la même façon
qu'il ya des enfants qui peuvent être
heureux quand il leur manque une main
l'état ne va pas créer d enfance en main
vous êtes d'accord
et pourtant peu et il arrive que des
enfants sans main soit heureux donc j'ai
suivi ce raisonnement de 10 réduiront
pas leur but moi je crois que j'ai
grandi dans un lagon taille actuelle on
est les faits les enfants handicapés
d'open je pense qu'un homme essaie ça
n'a pas loupé d'un enfant handicapé en
skiant qu'un enfant qui n'a pas de père
est un enfant qui a quelque chose en
moins oui c'est vrai d'accord on écoute
et là on est vraiment pas d'accord eh
bien oui merci d'un désaccord avec toute
la force de vos convictions je vous
propose d'attendre encore quelques
points de vue d'internautes olympe dg
qui nous dit on va vers de nombreuses
femmes seules avec enfant alors qu'il y
en a déjà beaucoup
mj pj smadja raison le principal est
d'avoir de bons parents mais le même
ajoute la question financière et surtout
le danger du parent unique m'inquiète
et puis ce point de vue de chardons
bleus qui craint que ces enfants passent
leur vie à chercher leur origine on
change